a pair of international pageant winners  are showing love knows no boundaries  Miss Argentina 2020 Mariana Varela  and Miss Puerto Rico 2020 Fabiola  Valentin said they got married last  month that's great news for these  beautiful young women I'm so glad they  got married but if you look at the  picture I don't see their husbands  anywhere  that's kind of weird these these two  they both got I guess they're very good  friends they got married on the same day  I guess well great but where are the  husbands I don't wait a second  hold on a minute here oh no they're  they're saying they got married to each  other but that's not possible because  they're girls they're both girls and two  girls can't get married to each other  because marriage intrinsically has to do  with sexual difference and  complementarity